well I say and I think I did say that
that that's ridiculous she's a parasite
she's first I'm you know a monumentally
moronic woman who got fired from the New
York Times who went into her business
having written in about about someone in
The New York Times and then invested in
her company
this woman is is is beyond the pale and
I assume she's just saying is this kind
of thing about about me because she
knows knows I will rise to the occasion
and she will get more publicity so so I
I don't think that I have to be the I
think it's it I this is a de facto case
of the parasite calling the parasite or
black or whatever the metaphor would be
I in any way I think she has a
ridiculous sight which contributes
nothing and serves no function and she
will shortly go out of business
the ultimate function is to give you the
news in a more efficient and more
entertaining way than you get it now so
it we certainly would would argue it
offers real and certain value
I think the daily basis is very good but
I don't think you're going to get your
your your your news a comprehensive
picture of the news in in a very quick
and entertaining way you're going to go
to The Daily Beast to read its its
articles many of which are good many of
which are way too long and The Daily
Beast is a as a source of of commentary
and and good and less good writing news
er is the news quick and fun
um I I would be and I guess I would I
know I would be on television I don't
know I would be I would be the president
of the United States